ما الذي يجب أن يركز عليه الناس في
العام الجديد ، نعم ، أعني ، أعتقد أنك تريد أن
تكون واقعيًا ولكنك تعرف الجرأة
الكافية أنك ستقوم
بالفعل ببعض التغييرات وأنت تعلم جون
أنا رجل دماغ لذلك أفكر في ذلك  الكثير من
هذه الأشياء من منظور
الدماغ ، غالبًا ما يقال إن ما هو
جيد للقلب مفيد أيضًا للدماغ
ولكن هناك بعض الاختلافات أيضًا ،
لذا أقسمها إلى نوع من هذه
الركائز الثلاث للصحة والتي ستعمل على
يبدو مألوفًا للناس ، لكنه في
الأساس عبارة عن حركة أستخدمها
بدلاً من ممارسة
التغذية ، أستخدم هذه الكلمة بدلاً من
النظام الغذائي
وبقية بالطبع ، تكون الحركة أو
التمرين على رأس قائمتك الآن أنت
عداء مما يجعلني أشعر بالغيرة
والغيرة  وإعجاب عميق ولكن بالنسبة
لبقيتنا الذين ربما لم يتم بناؤهم
بهذه الطريقة ، هناك وصفة طبية
لمقدار التمرين الذي نحتاجه للبدء
بشكل جيد هذه نقطة مثيرة للاهتمام
حقًا وأعتقد أننا نشهد تحولًا فيما
يتعلق بكيفية  نحن نعتقد  حول هذا الموضوع ،
لا تزال هناك إرشادات يقول الناس إن هناك 150
دقيقة يجب أن
تمارس فيها الرياضة كل
أسبوع ، وقد يفاجئك أو لا يفاجئك جون عندما
تعلم أن حوالي 80 في المائة من الأمريكيين
لا يصلون إلى هذا الهدف بحيث يكون هذا
مجرد نقطة بداية ولكن  أنا أيضًا
تعرف بشكل أساسي أن جون أنا
عداء ولكني أيضًا مؤمن أن
جسم الإنسان لم يكن مصممًا للجلوس أو الاستلقاء
لمدة 23 ساعة في اليوم ثم الذهاب للجري
لمدة ساعة
تعلمون أننا صممنا ليكون  التحرك
طوال اليوم وهو الوقت الذي نعمل فيه بشكل
أفضل من حيث كل هذه
العمليات المختلفة في أجسامنا الآن ، فإن فقدان
الوزن بالطبع هو في أسفل كل هذا
دائمًا قرار شائع دائم في نيويورك
للعام الجديد ولكن في حين أن المزيد من
التمرين هو المفتاح ، فهناك الآخر  جانب
من المعادلة ، فما الذي يجب أن نعرفه
عن الأكل
الجيد ، فأنت تعلم مرة أخرى أن هناك بعض
التحولات الثقافية في هذا وأنت تعلم أن
أحدهم يعتقد أنني أود إخبار
الناس وتذكيرهم هو أنه عندما
تأكل عندما تتصرف  إن استهلاك الطعام
هو الرسالة الأكثر اتساقًا
التي نقدمها لأجسادنا رسالة من
عالمنا الخارجي
إلى عالمنا الداخلي ، إنها إشارة تفكر
فيها كما لو أننا نفكر فيها من
حيث السعرات الحرارية والحنك والذوق بشكل
مفهوم ولكنها إشارة
أجسادنا وهناك جيش من
الكائنات الحية الدقيقة على سبيل المثال في أمعائنا
لدينا الميكروبيوم الذي يقف على أهبة
الاستعداد ليكون قادرًا على تفسير هذه الإشارة
والقيام بشيء حيال ذلك.قضيت بعض الوقت
في البودكاست الخاص بي أتحدث إلى دراما نايدو ،
إنها طبيبة نفسية طاهية التغذية  نوع
من هذا التهديد الثلاثي ،
فقط استمع إلى كيف تضع هذا
إذا كنا نأكل من أجل أجسامنا الداخلية ،
فإن الخارج سيتبع لأنه من خلال
رعاية
دماغنا ، حصلت على بقية أعضائنا
، سينخفض الوزن لأ
نا  سوف نتناول أطعمة صحية ،
لذا مرة أخرى هذه طريقة للتفكير في
الأمر ، لكن اسمحوا لي أن أتقدم بخطوة إلى الأمام
أخبرني بها الكثير من الناس
خاصة على مدار العامين
الماضيين.  تجعد مناعي ،
أريد بناء مناعة الآن ، ماذا
يعني ذلك تمامًا تمامًا أن
80 من مناعتك تكمن في
أمعائك ، يُطلق عليها اسم
النسيج الليمفاوي المرتبط بالأمعاء ، وهو الميكروبيوم
الذي أتحدث عنه وهناك
طرق لإنشاء  ميكروبيوم أكثر صحة
يمكن أن يساعد في تطعيمك من مرض
تعرفه ويعمل بسرعة كبيرة عندما
أتحدث إلى هؤلاء العلماء ، فإن ما
تناولته على الإفطار في أي يوم
يمكن أن يؤثر على مدى إصابتك
بعدوى أو أي شيء آخر في وقت لاحق من
تلك
الليلة  تعرف عندما تفكر في
تناول الطعام بهذه الطريقة ستأكل بشكل أفضل ، فإن
الوزن سينخفض كما قال الدكتور نايدو إذا كان هذ
هو الهدف ولكنك ستحصل على كل
ذه الفوائد الإضافية أفضل مي
روبيوم متنوع لذ
تناول الأطعمة المختلفة ال
ي تأكلها رائعة  أطعمة
مختلفة حسنًا ، أخيرًا نأتي للراحة وأنا
أعلم أنك اعترفت بأنك لا
تحصل دائمًا على قسط كافٍ من النوم وثالثًا أشبه تلك
الملاحظة بنفسي ، لذا ما مدى أهمية
إغفال أعينكم  جسم صحي
بشكل جيد ، هل يمكنني أن أقول فقط إن جون 2 لا
تتفاخر بقدرتك على إنجاز الكثير من
النوم القليل بعد الآن الذي اعتاد أن يكون
نقطة فخر أعتقد أن الكثير من
الناس لم أفكر في الأمر بهذه الطريقة
بعد الآن  على الإطلاق عندما تنظر
إلى العلم والأشياء الأساسية فقط مثل
أنا في أوائل الخمسينيات من عمري ، تبدأ الآن في
التفكير في الأشياء عندما تنظر إلى
البيانات وتقول إن الأشخاص الذين
ينامون أقل من ست ساعات
هناك  الارتباط لهؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
يحتمل أن ينتقلوا من
مرحلة ما قبل السكري إلى مرض السكري 44 زيادة
الخطر ، لذلك إذا كنت مثل شخص ما ، فأنا
أبلي بلاءً حسنًا حتى الآن ، فأنا لست
مصابًا بمرض السكري ولكني أشعر بالقلق حيال ذلك إذا
لم تكن مصابًا  ما يكفي من النوم الذي
يمكن أن يدفعك إلى حافة الهاوية ، فهذه
نوع ملموس أكثر فأنت تعرف الأشياء
التي ظهرت للضوء ولكني أعتقد أنك
تعرف ماذا ولماذا عندما
أحاول وشرح هذه الأشياء يمكنني أن أخبرك
بما يجب عليك فعله  لكن السبب في
اعتقادي
يجعله يلتصق فلماذا تنام
ال  هناك العديد من الأشياء المختلفة
ولكن هناك شيئان أعتقد أنهما يتبادران إلى ذهني دائمًا
أحدهما هو أنه حان الوقت الذي تقوم فيه
بتوحيد الذكريات بحيث تكون لديك هذه
التجارب المدهشة على مدار اليوم
ربما طوال موسم العطلات هذا بعد
ثلاث سنوات من الآن تريد
لتتذكرهم ، فأنت تعرفهم بوضوح شديد إذا
كنت تنام جيدًا ، فهذا هو الوقت الذي تُطبع فيه تلك
الذكريات قصيرة المدى نوعًا ما
في ذكريات طويلة المدى
بالنسبة للكثير منا ، لا يعني ذلك أننا ننسى
الأشياء ، بل إننا لم
نتذكرها أبدًا لأننا  عدم
الحصول على قسط كافٍ من النوم ، والشيء الآخر الذي
سأضيفه إلى ذلك هو أن لدينا
دورة الشطف المستمرة التي تحدث في
أجسامنا ، إنها غددنا الليمفاوية جيدًا ، وهناك
نوع مشابه من النظام يحدث
في الدماغ حيث تقوم
بإزالة  النفايات الأيضية التي
يمكن أن تكون مشكلة في وقت لاحق من الحياة
والتي تتراكم
في الليل أثناء النوم هي عندما تقوم
عادةً بإزالة معظم هذه النفايات ،
فأنت تفعل ذلك باستمرار ولكن
الأكثر فاعلية  الوقت الحالي هو في الليل ، لذا
من الواضح أن تنظيف النفايات يوطد
الذكريات ومزاج الناس
وكل شيء آخر قد تحسن أيضًا
ويبدو أنه صفقة جيدة جدًا في جميع
أنحاء الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا مع
نصائح مهمة للعقل والجسد والروح كما اتضح